Jeff of course will continue his
coverage of hurricane Florence just
ahead
more than 12,000 North Carolinians are
riding out the storm and shelters in
other parts of the state after the
hurricane forced them to get out of
their homes Elaine Quijano was at a
shelter in Garner North Carolina that's
just south of Raleigh Elaine good
morning good morning to you we are here
at garner high school just outside of
Raleigh this is one of about a hundred
and twenty six shelters that has opened
up across the state of North Carolina
and as you mentioned there are some
12,000 people who have sought shelter in
places like this and the governor says
if need be they'll be opening up even
more now I can tell you here at this
shelter eat is packed to capacity about
300 people or so spent the night here
and it has been as you can imagine a
restless night for many of these
evacuate a lot of the folks that I've
spoken with have come here from the
coast places like Jacksonville North
Carolina places like Swansboro North
Carolina Wilmington people here though a
lot of them have their family members
with them young children the elderly
they said it was a tough decision for
them to decide to pack up and leave but
ultimately given the forecast they said
they just could not take that chance now
though as you can only imagine they are
hearing a lot of this news coming out of
the coast it is a very anxious time for
them and they are hoping that eventually
as they are able to get back there that
they will still have homes to return to
but for now many of them are simply
hoping and praying here at this shelter
that the worst will pass and leave their
homes relatively unscathed viana of
course they all would have preferred to
stay at home but they can indeed call
themselves the lucky ones that are now
safe there in that shelter as you
mentioned 126 shelters we spoke with the
governor of South Carolina who said at
least in those shelters in his state
pets were allowed as well so many people
at home we were concerned about leaving
their pets that's good to know that you
can take them with you but Lila imagine
how hard it must be guys to be in a
shelter not knowing what's happening to
your house
may come home and everything that you
own everything you care about is gone
and I'm showing your life you'll be
there yes yeah it's a very scary
situation for everybody that is